hello everyone and welcome to the
champion showdown the chess960 edition
we've haven't seen a game in chess960 on
this channel in quite a while I think it
was the AL external degree versus magnus
carlsen game where agree sugar
checkmates caution in seven moves but
other than that I don't think we've
shown any other games and it was even
before I think chess calm had an option
on their interface to even show chess960
games for example I don't think castling
was allowed and or maybe I just didn't
know how to use it I don't know but here
it seems to be now a fully functional
interface and a lot of you said that you
would like to see a few of those games
so here we have Fabiana corona versus
garry kasparov very exciting matchup now
probably it wouldn't really make sense
for Kasparov to have a clash with any of
the top 10 players nowadays in real
chess as I don't think he's been
brushing up on his chest theory lately
but in chess960 there is no theory well
there could be but there are 960
starting positions of it I don't think
it's possible to memorize all the all
the openings from every possible
position but you know me if it is
possible for someone then that's a
different case and here they're using
this logo if they reseed the chest 9l x
LX seems to be for Roman numerals L
being 50 and X being 10 so that's just 9
16 I don't know how I feel about it see
it looks a bit weird but I don't know
maybe it will grow on me so this is game
2 in game 1 core wanna work as part of
had a better position but in the end the
game ended in a draw
Kasparov didn't find the absolute best
continuation which is hard of course in
a rapid game but here definitely the
most interesting game of their match
this is game 2 and if you enjoyed it if
you enjoy it maybe we can show some more
so without further ado cup Fabiano with
the white pieces opens with Knight to b3
sorry about that
we have d5 back as part of grabbing the
center with E for by Khurrana and d fork
as part of advances the point even
further with f4 and now II five by
casparo with F captures on e5 and Queen
475 and here our early centralization of
the Queen is not a problem as you don't
have a knight f3 like you would have a
normal chest to keep away the Queen so
here it's perfectly fine and we will not
be having any and it is as of this move
that we have a completely new game as
every game here is a completely new game
that's one of the you know reasons
people enjoy chess960 so much as
everything is a new game and you can
like live on RN and always says you can
start being creative starting for a move
one or maybe there is some sort of a
chess database regarding chess960 games
but even though I found some online I
don't know how complete they are or
should I even use them so for now we're
not gonna be using any nice the g3 by
Caruana
and now f6 by Kasparov in chess960 it's
almost always okay to play f6 with d3
and now c5 by Kasparov and it's very
interesting even though the positions
are perfectly symmetrical like in
regular chess it's already Kasparov who
is on the attack with the black pieces
we have C 3 and here Knight to c7 we
have keen to see to Caruana prepares a
rook to b1 and then he wants to talk to
the king to b1 not sure why why this is
so as he could just Castle if this is
what he wanted I'm sure he has his
reasons with rook to d7 Kasparov now
makes room for for the other look to
come here
probably why Khurana decided for
artificial castling before it doesn't
make much sense to place unlike Rudy -
to prepare castling because in chess960
you don't Castle by moving the King you
actually Castle by just shifting your
look over here like this and in regular
chess the castling is considered to be a
king's move so I don't know if that's
the case in chess960 probably it is as
even in the interface you have to move
your king in order to castle even though
the King stays on the exact same place
but ok Knights the f5 by Fabi
probably provoking weaknesses he wants
b6 to be played and here cos part of
just castles King side
Queen side sorry you can't just bring
the rook over here you have to move the
King and then castling the curse even
though the King hasn't really moved
anywhere
Bishop to f2 preparing to bring this
bishop over to this very nice diagonal
and now Knight to g6 back
part of we seek after Sundy for seek
after some before and now rugby c1
karana is now ready to Castle
artificially King to b8 getting the
river getting the King out of the C file
and now King b1 and here as there is a
lot of pressure against this d4 pawn
Kasparov eliminates one of the attackers
Bishop captures and b38 captures and now
Queen b5 Kasper now goes after the b3
pawn and already he crippled Coronas
Queen side quite a bit so karana
instead of defending starts attacking
rook c4 he goes after the d4 pawn
instead because part of defends it one
more time with Knights the e6 and now
before since the rook and Queen are now
guarding the b4 pond which Kasper wanted
to capture Knights the e5 trying to get
rid of the rook from from c4 but now
Bishop to g3
just pinning the knight not allowing
Knight captures rook with g6 pushing
away
Curran a strong night from f5 with
Knight to h4 and now Bishop to d6 I'm
painting now Knight captures rook is a
threat so Khurana has to give up his
dark square bishop here
Bishop captures on e5 with F captures on
e5 and now Knight back to f3 and here
it's a very good position for you to
pause the video because it's just 960
every position is a new position
Kasparov has a very promising position
here you are welcome to study it pause
the video here and what would you play
here I will give you a couple of seconds
to pause the video if you would like so
so for those of you who have paused the
video and found the night the c7 you are
an exceptional player as casparo played
looked the c7 here night to c7 is a bit
more precise as after night to a6 and
Knight captures on before there is a
very little white can do here for
example if you play rook DC 1 you have
to prepare Bishop e2 to d1 to guard the
a Foursquare Knights the a6 Bishop to e2
now you can capture on before night
chapter some before and now Bishop to be
one very important not allowing ideas
like Queen here to mate or or even if
Queen to a5 you can always block mate
with Bishop to b3 guarding the a2 square
so there should be one very important
but now you play a five you start
pushing and it will be it will be
extremely difficult to defend this but
okay Erica Sparrow played a different
line we have looked to see seven and now
comes G three by Caruana taking away the
F four square from Kasparov tonight and
now as far off as he can no longer push
with the rooks along the C file he
decides to take it to the F file as now
the knight on f3 is unguarded so he
doesn't lose any time
rook to f8 attacking the knight Bishop
to e2 defending and now rook C to f7
with the threat of just two rook
captures on f3 and here
rook d c1 karana now prevents capture
with attacking because if captures
captures captures you're getting made it
rook the c8 is mate
so Kasparov takes this opportunity and
plays F a five and this is just
wonderful now Kasparov is attacking on
both sides of the board before his
hanging or knight on f3 is hanging there
is no mate after that X after that trade
because he also now freed the a7 square
for his King it's a very difficult
position for Caruana to play with Queen
to d1 now the queen guards the knight on
f3
but now Prospero just takes the b4 phone
but should capture Sun before and Queen
to b3 happening the bishop also helping
out with with the the defense here but
now just rook captures on f3 it doesn't
lose a piece because well tactics still
allow Corona to defend with Bishop
captures and the rook captures but now
rook to c8
check King to a7 and now picking up the
knight on e6 we have Queen captures on
e6 and here casparo plays rush of the c3
already threatening Queen captures unbe
to mate and how do you defend this you
have to bring your Queen back to help
out with the defense with Queen to a2
and here casparo just picks up yet
another pawn rook captures on d3 and now
it's very dangerous here it's hard hard
to find the defense moves like rook to
d2 are coming adding yet another
attacker to the B to pawn karana plays
rook the c4 now he's hoping for rook the
d2 to meet this with rook to c2 just
hanging in there hoping the mattel guard
everything but Kasparov played a most
interesting move after look the c-4
Kasparov played Bishop captures and b2
which is which is just great as of
course you're hoping for Queen captures
and rook to b3 just picking up the Queen
like this captures in rugby 3 will pick
up the Queen with check what Kasparov
should have done instead of this Bishop
captures NB to move is Rookie three and
now you just pick up the e4 pawn you
have to connected passed pawns in the
center karana is dead lost here which is
what the quote above the board basically
says even not making a move wins here
for black but this is what Kasparov
should have done for example after b3
you're gonna go Queen to b6 and after
Queen to a for now butcher back to
before you're guarding everything with
your bishop if white wants to get out of
this mess he will he will have to give
up a look at some point but it will not
help him you're gonna eliminate d4 pawn
and then have to connected pass pawns in
the center of the board
but Kasparov played Bishop captures and
b2 and it allows Corona a very delicate
defensive maneuver so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this defensive
maneuver while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent defender of really hard to
defend positions and for those who just
want to enjoy the show obviously if you
found Queen captures and b2 you haven't
been paying attention very well but if
you found rock the c5 then you are
really a remarkable defender as now you
have problems there are no good
discoveries any discovery will be met
with the simple route capture screen
which comes with check and if you move
the Queen well you lose the a 5 point
with check but Kasparov has no options
here Queen before was played rook
captures on a5 with check now you can't
go to be it because rook e8 is just made
this rook controls the entire C file so
Kasparov played King to be 6 but now
rook the a4 and here's the problem if
you play Queen B 5:26 check just wins
the Queen the rook controls the a file
district
the C file you have to block with the
Queen and then it's just rook captures
and black falls apart so Kasparov played
Queen to b3 but don't remember don't
forget to you just sacrifice the bishop
so you can't really trade Queens but
there are no other moves so Corona
played Queen captures on b2 and it was
in this position that Gary Kasparov
resigned the game so really an exciting
game of course now there's nothing to do
after captures captures Kasparov is just
down the whole rook that's it's an
unplayable position but it's very very
interesting and it's very interesting
how Kasparov can hold his own against
Corona up until he blunders for example
like in Game one he had a better
position but ended in a draw and here he
had a completely winning position with
the black pieces and then he just played
this Bishop character son b2 wanted to
finish the game in style when in fact he
had to slow down go after the pawn
create two connected passed pawns and so
on but yeah this is game 2 really
exciting it's been like I said it's been
a long time since we've covered a
chess960 game so I do hope you enjoyed
it and if you would enjoy more games
from the Kasparov Caruana match where
we're gonna talk a bit more about the
standings or from the other matches as
well do share your thoughts in the
comment section so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Jeff grapes
Jeff graves William Carney Dan O'Hanlon
Parker Grand Prix and Michael Hill
apiece for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the kappa blanka saga maybe
checking off a few more games from this
championship showdown or as they call it
the chess 9l x showdown and yeah that's
pretty much it thank you I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day